le moment Marco Mouli le 10 novembre
prochain il est convoqué pour une
enquête dans laquelle il mise en cause
pour des faits de tentatives d'obtention
frauduleuses des tensions et usages de
documents administratifs c'est une
affaire qui date de 2016 il l'a révélé
dans son livre il l'a révélé sur le
plateau de TPMP et il demande pourquoi
aujourd'hui 6 ans après il reviennent et
le convoque petit récap et on sera avec
lui et mettre Moura de bâti c'est parti
le mois dernier Marco Molly était venu
sur notre plateau pour faire la
promotion de son ouvrage La Cavale dans
le livre il y a des choses c'est que la
vérité dans son livre celui qui est
considérait comme le Roi de l'Arnaque
raconte son incroyable périple pour
échapper à la prison bon la robe
d'avocat je vois une paire de lunettes
rouges je commence à courir comme un
voleur mais sur notre plateau Marco
Molly c'est aussi laisser aller à
quelques confessions de réussir à passer
avec des passeports qui ne me
ressemblent pas ça veut dire qu'en
vérité c'est le Moulin Rouge des
confessions qui lui valent aujourd'hui
d'être rattrapés par la justice
poursuivi pour ses propos tenus dans
l'émission
Marco boulis s'explique ce soir dans
TPMP
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu me vois tu peux sourire au moins quoi
bonjour
Il est en train de vérifier ses comptes
et tout il est pas je te jure
ou pas il est sur ses comptes sur ces
trucs voilà et donc il est des fois il a
des petites absences comment ça va mon
chéri
j'ai envie de retoucher pour être
connards
moi ça regarde-moi ça
j'aime bien en plus là le problème on
m'a demandé d'être comme ça ah pourquoi
j'aime ta tenue j'adore pourquoi tu as
demandé
il y a une gonzesse qui est rentré de
folie elle a été aux toilettes tu vois
l'odeur normal elle m'a tué
je te remercie pour ce témoignage merci
Marco pour ce témoignage merci Mourad en
tout cas tu as l'air hyper content de
voir Marco enchanté
avocat pénaliste un ami de l'émission
d'accord
j'aimerais bien l'avoir en face de moi
mais désolé c'est rien pour toi ça veut
dire quoi
tu es fier d'être devant Marc
est-ce que Marco moulin un jour d'avoir
un dialogue avec moi c'est beau ne mens
pas ou sinon on va y aller
c'est quoi cette histoire alors Marco
non mais c'est elle est grave cette
histoire elle est grave
pas à comprendre l'affaire est de 2016
alors on va on va rappeler non mais
vas-y Marco parce que en fait tu dis
dans ton livre le livre La Cavale écrit
avec Julie Mada Marco Molly on en a
parlé longuement dans cette émission
d'ailleurs vous aviez adoré cette
émission vous avez été très très
nombreux à la regarder ou Marco nous
racontait sa cabane nous raconter et
notamment tu peux peut-être nous
raconter tu as fait des faux papiers
ouais enfin j'avais pas fait de moi
j'avais fait des faux papiers c'est ce
que tu dis dans les mais j'avais aussi
pris des papiers des papiers des autres
d'accord passeport des autres donc parce
que tu étais en cavale bah comment tu
aurais pu faire ah oui bah c'est sûr tu
vas pas si je me présente avec Marco
Bouly je suis mort oui donc j'ai été et
puis là je reçois une convocation
faut usage de faux papiers
je les appelle je leur dis bonjour c'est
Monsieur Moulis monsieur Mouli ça voilà
alors on a la convocation regardez
tentative d'obtention frauduleuse de
documents administratifs des tensions et
usages de faux documents administratif
commis le 24 mai 2016 à et a changé à
changer son nom
c'est une ville bien sûr ça a changé
c'est pas ça d'accord je savais même pas
parce que j'ai pas été
papiers étaient faux papiers ont été
fait là-bas en fait bah voilà donc tu
sais il y a des faux comptes sur
Instagram il y a des faucons il y a des
faux papiers que des gens vont c'est les
gens ils sont un peu fans ils ont envie
de peut-être me ressembler donc ils vont
faire des papiers à mon nom il y a une
chose que je sais c'est que là le plus
important c'est qu'en 2016 on me fait
une enquête sur 2016 c'est presque en
2023 j'ai envie de comprendre comment
une fois que je passe chez toi toi tu
dis que la vérité ça veut dire que tu
laisses le peuple parler de leur chaud
de leur problème donc merci pour m'avoir
aidé pour faire vendre mon lit pour pour
avoir l'écriture et la lecture de mon
livre et la vérité aujourd'hui se fait
pourquoi c'est à dire que dans mon livre
j'ai pas menti parce qu'il y a la preuve
aujourd'hui que la justice va me faire
un peu de bobo à mon avis c'est que j'ai
plutôt une grosse gueule et qu'ils ont
envie que j'arrête j'ai entendu qu'ils
veulent arrêter mon livre c'est sûr et
certain ils veulent l'arrêter là c'est
sûr parce que ça fait mal à beaucoup de
gens c'est à dire et bah comment je m'en
suis sorti pour cette cavale parce que
la cavale existe si moi j'ai fait 14
pays donc il se disent ils sont en train
d'enquêter sur ça ça veut dire que ils
vont enquêter dans 14 pays avec quel
papier je suis passé et le problème
c'est que est-ce que tu vas m'envoyer
des mandats si je suis en prison
voilà ma peur est là la vapeur est
vraiment là parce que tu as peur de
retourner en prison bah ouais ça serait
idiot de dire que j'ai pas peur d'aller
en prison tu as raison c'est horrible la
prison la prison il faut pas y aller
donc là là tu es passé dans l'émission
tu as reçu ce courrier combien de temps
après la semaine dernière la semaine
dernière la semaine dernière les
missions elle a trois semaines la
semaine dernière j'ai reçu ils ont
trouvé quelque chose dans 3 semaines je
sais pas comment ils ont fait
normalement ils auraient dû le trouver
en 2016 et là on est en 2022 donc ce que
tu révèles dans ton livre pour eux c'est
passible de d'une peine de prison c'est
ça ouais je sais pas si tu me prête
parce que ça t'avais pas tu as pas été
jugé pour ça non enfin moi je ponce bon
il y a un avocat moi je pense que moi je
pense que tout est mis dans la même
chose quand tu prends 8 ans tu prends 8
ans pour tout c'est la justice il savait
que je me suis du meilleur cavale il
savait que j'avais pas pensé moi
donc je sais pas si on peut séparer les
affaires mais en réalité non on peut pas
séparer les affaires parce que l'affaire
du carbone
c'est la même affaire pour tout si après
vous séparez tous les dossiers je vais
prendre 200 ans de prison donc c'est là
le problème donc à mon avis ils peuvent
pas mais j'essaye de le faire ils
essayent de le faire mais on voit que
j'ai tout dit la vérité dans la cavale
dans le livre la cavale et c'est ça en
fait qui pose problème voilà le problème
c'est qu'ils ont vu que c'était la
réalité je pense que ça embête des
personnes d'accord je pense je sais pas
s'il faut le dire ou pas
alors on est en direct non je pense que
tu me le dire dans l'oreille non bon on
va le dire non non ne le dis pas non moi
aussi on va le dire je pense que quand
on est amis avec toi il y a beaucoup de
gens qui aiment pas
ça tu peux le dire toi t'inquiète pas
serré donc comme tu peux toi grâce à
Dieu tu as pas de casserole grâce à Dieu
de tes nets dans tes comment on dit
vous le savez je voulais te laisser
parler
on a envie de m'attaquer un petit peu tu
as compris et je pense que le problème
il est là aujourd'hui de dire la vérité
toi quand tu prends du public quand tu
prends des gens pour parler un peu de
des choses qui font que des choses
qu'ils ont tu parles ouvertement et puis
ça embête beaucoup de gens voilà et je
pense que là je vais avoir du du fil à
Tordre
je te sens inquiet
un petit peu tu sais d'aller au
commissariat
je ne sais pas les preuves qu'ils ont je
ne sais pas où ils vont en venir mais
bien entendu attention j'ai eu des flics
de folie vraiment gentil vraiment
vraiment j'adore non là je suis pas
hypocrite enfin un petit peu je
le rendez vous on verra comment ça va se
passer tu sais que c'est le 10 novembre
je ne sais pas comment ça va se passer
et je ne sais pas qui a derrière le
problème c'est qu'on m'a dit qu'il y
avait des gens derrière et je pense que
c'est un peu à cause de toi
c'est fou ça pour toi ouais vraiment ah
ouais parce que tu as attaqué quelqu'un
de t'attaquer quelqu'un et je pense
qu'ils vont en faire son son cheval de
bataille moi est-ce que tu penses que
c'est possible ça alors moi je sais pas
mais en tout cas ce qui est vrai et je
comprends l'inquiétude de Monsieur Molly
on peut quand même se questionner sur
cette auto saisine du parquet parce que
en réalité ce que Monsieur mouillé a
fait c'est qu'il a raconté une
infraction qui est la commise en 2016
alors d'abord je tiens à vous rassurer à
mon avis il y a quand même un enjeu
procédural parce que 2016 plus 6 on est
en 2022 donc il me semble que les faits
sont prescrits donc je comprends même
pas pourquoi est-ce que vous avez été
convoqué parce qu'à mon sens il y a une
prescription ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que il y a une
auto-césine du parquet pour quelque
chose qui est quand même pas gravissime
c'est un délit et je dois le dire et je
le dis comme je le pense il y a des
écrivains des hommes politiques des
cinéastes des grands penseurs qui ont
écrit des choses
ignobles bien plus grave que celle que
Marco Mouli a écrit et qui n'ont pas été
poursuivi il a fallu attendre que des
plaignants des pauses pleines pour être
poursuivi et là concernant monsieur
Mouli effectivement il y a une auto
saisine qui à mon sens questionne et à
questionne d'autant plus quand on sait
effectivement j'ai vu plusieurs de vos
interventions médiatiques monsieur Mouli
quand on sait le parcours qui est le
vôtre puisque
vous avez
un centre que vous avez quel âge j'ai 37
ans
il me semble il me semble que vous avez
payé votre dette à la société que vous
avez remboursé une grande partie de
votre dette là où beaucoup à votre place
là où beaucoup à votre place auraient
organisé leur insolvabilité donc vous
êtes plutôt dans une réinsertion qui
donne des preuves et des gages à la
justice à la société à la République
donc je pense à mon sens que ça avait un
peu dans le sens d'un excès de zèle et
je vous avoue que je ne comprends pas
bien cette auto-césine compte tenu de
votre parcours et de ce que ça te
rassure ce que je viens de dire
mots que jamais appris de ma vie auto
saisine c'est quoi tous ces inteau
saisine c'est
quand tu es en voiture avec tes saisies
voilà c'est c'est
ce que je comprends dans votre dossier
c'est que personne n'a déposé plein de
contre vous il a fallu attendre que vous
écriviez un livre et que vous vous auto
directement pour que le procureur se
saisisse de votre dossier c'est à dire
que l'autocéine si vous ne si vous ne
dites pas ce que vous avez dit dans
votre livre avec une certaine sincérité
et bien vous ne seriez pas poursuivi et
là
parce que vraisemblablement le ministère
public l'accusation a eu votre livre
donc c'est déjà quelque chose donc vous
pouvez vous enorgueillir et j'étais au
palais tout le monde l'avait mon livre
et du coup ils ont décidé de vous
poursuivre sur une infraction pour
laquelle vous n'avez pas été poursuivi
jusque-là mais encore une fois à mon
sens il est possible que vous ayez une
belle surprise lors de votre convocation
parce que à mon sens les faits sont
prescrits sauf des exceptions très
précises mais 2016 on arrive en mai 2022
je suis pas d'accord avec toi sur la
prescription pourquoi je ne suis pas
d'accord aujourd'hui la prescription
n'existe plus je t'expliquer pourquoi
les listes plus même si je te le dis en
tant qu'avocat c'est qu'aujourd'hui
avant d'attendre les cinq ans quand il y
a des personnages comme moi qu'est-ce
qu'ils font ils lancent une procédure
sur la prescription et ça repart sur
cinq ans donc ça n'existe plus la
précision tu sais on n'est pas maître de
nous-mêmes aujourd'hui la justice est un
bled c'est un monde c'est eux qui
décident tout ce qui vote ce qu'ils
veulent pas quand tu vas aller c'est
même les avocats les pauvres je vous
plains pas les avocats vous avez un
problème vous êtes là vous êtes des
vendeurs d'espoir vous essayez de faire
sortir des clients il y a rien de
méchant mais vous faites pas le poids
contre si le procureur
comme ça il s'en foutent ce qu'il dit le
procure elle s'en fout ce que tu dis toi
elle va mettre la peine qu'elle a envie
de mettre c'est pour ça que on est dans
une justice qui n'est pas une justice en
réalité 2016 on vient convoque ça y est
mais j'ai pas des choses à faire moi je
suis rentré dans le droit chemin
aujourd'hui on m'a donné le choix et
l'avantage merci Cyril c'est beau comme
je te fais des compliments un amour non
mais c'est beau là mais si je te fous
dans la merde on m'a donné on m'a donné
le choix de faire autre chose et là on
ne veut pas que je le fasse là on
m'emmerde on m'emmerde parce que c'est
fatiguant d'être c'est horrible Marco je
te sens inquiet je te sens triste tout
le monde me sens comme ça sur ce plateau
même les gens voilà qui qui réagissent
sur les réseaux et c'est vrai que non
mais c'est vrai que cette histoire on te
sent pénible enfin on te sent inquiet
pour cette affaire puisque tu vas tu as
été convoqué tu nous as dit le 10
novembre pour cette affaire de faux
papiers et moi j'étais persuadé je te
dis que ça avait été jugé avant dans un
cadre global de ta peine puisque tu as
purgé 8 ans de prison désolé mais je le
sentais moi aussi je le voyais pas venir
là je le voyais vraiment pas venir et
comme il m'a dit un député je peux
donner son nom si c'est lui qui c'est
toi qui vois c'est pour lui c'est pour
lui il y a un député qui t'a dit quoi il
m'a dit comme quoi Marco Molly tu vas
avoir des problèmes à cause de Cyril
enfin je sais pas si on doit dire à
cause ou pour Cyril à cause à cause de
Cyril parce que tes potes avec lui on
peut pas l'attaquer en direct donc on
t'attaque à toi voilà et je lui c'est
qui quoi comment il m'a dit bah regarde
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé la semaine
dernière où il y a 2 semaines voilà donc
on est là aujourd'hui
c'est un député que tu as dit ça qui t'a
c'est un député de droite incroyable il
veut bien le dire si tu veux bah si
la goder c'est un gueulard
il a eu cette info il t'a dit cette info
comme tout le monde a des infos de toute
façon entre eux ils ont tous des infos
c'est ça se mélange bien là-bas ils sont
ennemis dans la chambre ils sont amis
après c'est tout ça c'est du cinéma donc
après tout le monde se prend en vidéo
c'est pour ça que les téléphones sont
interdits en vidéo il y a plein de
choses qui se passent donc aujourd'hui à
l'heure actuelle les faits sont là voilà
ils sont là ils sont réels ils sont
concrets et je voulais te dire quelque
chose mettre euh enfin comment il
s'appelle Mourad basique sincèrement tu
m'as plumes comment tu as parlé et ben
je vais te prendre dans cette affaire tu
penses que tu en es capable on va
travailler ensemble non le mot c'est pas
tu en es capable non le mot c'est pas là
mais moi je vais pas entendre ça je veux
dire t'inquiète pas tu vas pas en prison
comment vas-y tu me veux tu me dises
t'inquiète pas tu vas pas en prison
Marco mon lit vous n'allez pas aller en
prison je t'aime mon frère
c'est incroyable ce qui se passe sur ce
plateau en direct New York il y a aucune
autre qui sourit pas ça moi vraiment
pensé que vous êtes loin pour les pays
spectateurs qui nous écoutent pensez
vraiment que vous avez les arguments
pour aujourd'hui tu vas plus avoir un
client dans le cadeau voilà tu es mort
tu l'as dites moi
objectivement encore une fois cette
cette convocation à mon sens elle est
parfaitement scandaleuse encore une fois
c'est quelqu'un qui serait insère bon
voilà c'est quelqu'un qui a du bagou qui
parle fort etc mais ça n'est pas une
raison pour qu'il soit convoqué qu'on
vienne fouiller son passé qu'on vienne
fouiner son livre pour encore une fois
ce qui n'est qu'un délit c'est à dire
que dans l'échelle des infractions il y
a les contraventions il y a les délits
il y a les crimes on est tout en bas des
infractions donc j'ai l'impression qu'on
vient quand même chercher des poux à mon
client je peux le dire maintenant
j'ai l'impression qu'on vient quand même
chercher des poux à mon client et je
trouve que c'est parfaitement injustifié
on le fera savoir le moment venu il y a
un autre alors il y a un député qui
m'écrit en même temps qui me dit Cyril
je te confirme que c'est pas peut-être
peut être impossible l'histoire que
raconte Marco
non mais c'est sûr
et je voulais dire une chose seulement
moi je t'invite à dîner j'ai entendu que
je t'addition sur moi je t'aime je
t'aime je t'aime
c'est important
[Applaudissements]
parce que je te le dis tu en auras pas
des des plans comme ça tu en auras pas
beaucoup
vous vous êtes entre guillemets attaquer
l'émission s'est attaqué au garde des
sceaux on va dire les noms monsieur
Dupont
moi je vais le dire donc le Garde des
Sceaux est puissant
il a pas très bien pris ce qui a été dit
sur lui c'est quelqu'un qui a une très
haute conception de lui-même il n'avait
déjà pas très bien pris que Monsieur
Darmanin soit votre invité parce
qu'entreprise
et il a dit ça le lendemain de
l'émission avec Charles Darman ce n'est
pas hasard il y a quelque chose
qu'il a irrité effectivement c'est que
on remette en question sa légitimité ne
supporte pas ça donc
j'ai pas les mêmes sources que vous mais
c'est tout à fait plausible c'est même
très possible vous avez des sources où
oui mais c'est vrai vous vous agacez
monsieur Dupont-Moretti monsieur
Dupont-Moretti à la réputation de alors
j'ai employé un mot fort mais en restant
dans le registre d'avocat de vouloir à
chaque fois lorsqu'il était avocat
Maître bâti pourra sans doute le
confirmer il détruisait ses opposants il
détruisait la partie adverse de manière
violente verbalement verbalement et donc
là pardon c'était son métier c'était son
métier mais il était très antagoniste et
il en veut à l'émission oui c'est vrai
il en veut à l'émission
il hésite ou il va venir moi je pense
qu'il ne viendra pas ça n'engage que moi
peut-être j'aurais des problèmes mais je
pense qu'il n'aura pas le courage de
venir en terrain hostile voilà c'est mon
opinion elle n'engage que moi et
effectivement il cherche des angles pour
attaquer donc ça m'étonne pas que vous
soyez convoqué pour ça vous les avez
énervés quand vous avez parlé de Moulin
Rouge parce que quand vous avez dit dans
l'émission Moulin Rouge ça veut dire que
ils font pas leur boulot la faute
de la faire des passeports on a revu
l'extrait tout à l'heure vous avez dit
bah j'ai j'ai refait des documents mais
j'ai pas mis j'ai pas mis Marco Molly et
ça fait très Moulin Rouge sous-entendu
on peut se balader à travers les
frontières de 14 pays les Guignols voilà
exactement donc ça ça les a énervé je
pense que quand vous irez à l'audition
il vous parleront de ce mot Moulin Rouge
d'ailleurs vous me direz excuse-moi
quand j'irai à l'édition je pense que je
vais te laisser une place dans ma
cellule parce qu'il y avait tout ce que
tu as dit tu es mort
je le dis parce que je le pense et parce
que c'est vrai voilà
tu dis ce que tu penses ou tu as
vraiment des infos non dans le j'ai pas
des infos de députés mais dans le milieu
disons médiatique bien informé moi il y
a des gens qui m'ont dit les gars vous
avez dépassé les bandes vous allez avoir
des problèmes voilà ça on me l'a dit
très clairement pourquoi et j'ai le
problème des journalistes voilà des
journalistes bien informés qui m'ont dit
vous avez dépassé entre guillemets vous
avez été très loin avec Monsieur
Dupont-Moretti vous allez avoir le
maximum de problèmes et de vous faire
reste à savoir s'il peut nous faire des
problèmes non mais je dis pas ça Cyril
je dis pas que vous aurez des problèmes
je pense qu'il vaut mieux qu'il vienne
et voilà parce que c'est lui qui a parlé
de nous après moi je pense qu'il va
finir parvenir m'arrête là je le sens
comme ça je vous le dis on verra bien
moi je sens qu'il va finir par venir
parce que il y a beaucoup de gens qui
veulent aussi le voir ici et je pense
qu'il a envie de parler aux Français
parce que il leur parle pas dans les
émissions sur lesquelles il va et c'est
des émissions auxquelles il voilà dans
lesquels voilà il est déjà on le connaît
déjà donc il faudrait qu'il vienne dans
une émission où ils se mettent un petit
peu en danger mais oui il parle à des
Français qui ont pas l'habitude de le
voir donc moi je pense qu'il va il va
finir parvenir oui Géraldine non mais
moi je vous crois Marco risque d'autant
plus que votre livre il est formidable
et vous avez été édité par un grand
éditeur Harper's Collins donc en fait
ils ont lu tout ça il y a les services
juridiques dans les maisons d'édition
qui contrôle pour que justement vous
n'ayez pas un nouveau problème avec la
justice donc en fait ça tient ce que
vous dites moi je pense vous avez raison
mais je pense qu'il ne risque rien parce
que sinon l'éditeur il aurait pas planté
comme ça il aurait pas dit vas-y écris
ça c'est bon tu risques d'aller en tôle
en fait c'est un trop grand risque pour
vous est-ce que vous comprenez Marco
si tu penses le 10 tu vas kiffer mais en
tous les cas merci beaucoup de remonter
le moral mais moi je vais te dire la
vérité à chaque fois que j'ai appelé la
police pour leur dire c'est quoi il me
dit c'est rien t'inquiète pas tu ressors
l'après-midi même et je me suis retrouvé
en prison à chaque fois donc la vérité
franchement je vais y aller avec mon sac
je vais mettre mes cigarettes mon
jogging moi doudoune on sait jamais
autant de savoir si tu vas avoir froid
ou pas donc je ne vais pas penser
normalement comme il dit maître et je
fais confiance même si on était mort
même plus dans l'émission je te fais un
bordel je vais aller avec Maître tu es
mon nouvel avocat on peut le dire à tout
le monde c'est bon tu sais qu'on a des
tonnes qui vont être mes avocats donnent
je te le dis il y en a des tonnes qui
veulent être mes clients
vraiment pas envie d'avoir froid amène
Daniel avec toi tu verras elle peut
chauffer une ville entière tous les
rajouter un truc
d'une potentielle vengeance c'est que
Marco il avait déjà écrit dans son livre
et c'est après seulement être passé dans
tes PMB qu'il a eu des problèmes donc si
vraiment les propos qui posaient
problème il vous aurait embêté juste
après le livre là c'est pépé qui a posé
problème donc c'est un crédit de ces
tests de la montagne après peut-être que
je vous dire aussi peut-être que tu es
pimpé a mis en lumière le livre tout le
monde n'a pas le livre alors que tu es
presb voilà c'est vrai que il a fait un
énorme score ce soir là d'audience Marco
tu avais cartonné chez nous donc
forcément il y a beaucoup de gens qui
ont vu l'émission aussi qui sont ni
tiens je vais me replonger dans le livre
aussi je pense qu'il y a ça aussi c'est
à toi qui est le numéro 1 quand même le
livre
justement merci alors je suis là qui
veut faire de la pub à aller chez Cyril
et vous allez en prison après voilà